every lawyer always puts their clients
interests first and is always a paragon
of virtue
all right
i couldn't even say that with this right
face but the vast majority of attorneys
serve their clients with honor and
distinction well
the majority a majority of lawyers know
some lawyers serve their clients with
honor and distinction and yet lawyers
have long been the target of jokes and
media portrayals that depict us as a
uniquely unethical occupation and as for
your case don't you worry i've argued in
front of every judge in the state often
as a lawyer but even though most lawyers
choose the straight and narrow path
others have
broken bad so today let's not talk about
those good lawyers you never hear about
let's talk about when lawyers have gone
wild
sets you free so let's start with the
lawyer who defrauds yes a nine-year-old
girl with grandpa's help now one of the
cardinal duties of legal representation
is undivided loyalty to clients under
this ethical mandate lawyers have a
legal obligation not to enrich
themselves to the client's detriment and
to zealously advocate for a client's
interest above our own personal desires
but that's exactly what vincent j
tremarco jr did not do he's a long
island litigator who conspired with
client gary erickson to slowly steal two
million dollars of inheritance from
erickson's nine-year-old granddaughter
and tremarco's client rebecca shaffer
now miss schaefer was set to receive
millions from a federal wrongful death
settlement involving her father who died
at age 20 in jail while serving a
misdemeanor for drug charge from april
2012 through august 2017 tremarco and
the co-conspirator grandfather
orchestrated a scheme to steal millions
of dollars from a fatherless child they
purchased luxury vehicles including a
ferrari 430 spyder for 200 000 and a
jaguar xkr convertible for 57 000 and
they spent over 600 thousand dollars to
purchase several properties throughout
suffolk county new york and they even
invested over eight hundred thousand
dollars of ill-gotten gains in the
emporium a now defunct nightclub and
music venue in new york that tremarco
was at times part owner of and while mr
tremarco must have gotten his legal
training from the lionel hud school of
law clearly the grandfather learned his
family skills from lucille bluth oh
don't give me that look
i happen to be a more caring mother than
most and in october 2017 federal
prosecutors unveiled a 19 count
indictment against framarco for
conspiracy to commit mail fraud wire
fraud money laundering and other charges
related to the multi-million dollar
theft grandfather eriksen who died
before the investigation was completed
was named as an unindicted
co-conspirator but in october 2020
tremarco pleaded guilty to the charges
in announcing the sentence u.s attorney
breon peace outlined why trumarco's
breach of his fiduciary duty to his
client was so egregious quote
charmarco's theft of a seven-figure
inheritance from a child so that he
could purchase luxury vehicles and
invest in real estate is a disgraceful
breach of trust and betrayal of his
time-honored duties as an attorney his
conduct is an affront to the courts the
bar and the community at large today's
sentence should serve as a warning that
this office will prosecute corrupt
attorneys who abuse their positions and
break the law for personal gain and in
december 2021 chermarko was sentenced to
57 months in prison ordered to pay
restitution of 1.5 million and forfeit
the amount of 1.5 million dollars and
shortly after sentencing the new york
grievance committee which regulates
attorney conduct in the state
retroactively disbarred for marco as of
his october 2020 guilty plea but it's
not just lawyers who have gone bad it's
also judges and that takes us to the
shirtless judge who sent explicit photos
of himself to the bailiff and then
impregnated a witness in his judicial
chambers now judges have this reputation
for being stuffy humorless old men and
robes but in the case of judge wade
harper mccree who is neither old stuffy
nor humorless he would still be a judge
if he had kept his robe on because in
2012 judge mccree was serving on the
third circuit court in wayne county
michigan where he specialized in sexual
misconduct cases no i'm not making that
up you would think that with that
experience he would have known better
than to send a bare-chested photo of
himself to a female bailiff
this is inappropriate workplace conduct
and neither the bailiff nor her husband
found it amusing the judge who was also
married was confronted with a print out
of the photo by local news by replying
hot dog yep
that's me
mccree whose father served under
president jimmy carter as the second
african-american solicitor general in
the united states history was unbothered
by the misconduct allegations stating
quote i've got no shame in my game good
god man
but he later admitted to sending the
photo to other women now judge mccree
might have been able to weather this
sexting scandal but his inability to
keep it in his robe led to a spectacular
public downfall while presiding over a
child support case in 2013 judge mccree
repeatedly used his judicial chambers
for extramarital trysts with a witness
in his case between may and november of
2012 did you engage in sexual conduct
with judge mccree yes i do sneak the
witness a cell phone in violation of
security protocol so that he could
regularly text her during trial got the
witness pregnant urged her to terminate
the pregnancy and then repeatedly lied
about the episode under oath no it's
salesman's puffery not surprisingly the
judge was formally removed from the
bench in 2014 barred from being a judge
for six years i don't know why only six
years and following a three-year
suspension of his law license the
shirtless judge's license was reinstated
in 2020 so now that mccree has been
given a second chance at a legal
practice perhaps going forward he could
stand to have just a little more shame
in his game but that takes us to the
caveman lawyer who stalked his
ex-girlfriend repeatedly shoots her
office with a crossbow and got disbarred
for it now what sets modern man apart
from neanderthal ancestors is the
ability to work out disputes using words
instead of brute force
sometimes
but in the case of stephen a weinkoff
this california caveman lawyer decided
that the way to address his hurt
feelings toward his lawyer ex-girlfriend
was not to use his words but his
crossbow and it cost him his law license
his reputation and millions of dollars
because in the early 2010s weinkoff
began a romantic relationship with
fellow attorney adriana last name
redacted when they worked together in
the san francisco county public
guardian's office the relationship ended
in december 2013 and while the
girlfriend moved on weinkoff did not the
girlfriend installed security cameras at
her law office after finding crossbow
arrows shot into her building's windows
in april june and august of 2015. and in
january 2017 surveillance videos showed
someone in a red jeep firing a gun at
the building cracking a window five days
later the same red jeep drove by at
night and fired another crossbow at the
office and the girlfriend was able to
identify her assailant as none other
than weinkoff weinkoff was arrested and
convicted of felony stalking with
enhanced penalties for using a deadly
weapon the state bar deemed this offense
moral turpitude and weinkoff was
disbarred in 2020 that same year
weinkoff was found simply liable for
stalking intentional infliction of
emotional distress and domestic violence
against his ex-girlfriend at trial
weinkoff admitted to shooting the
crossbow one time but denied the other
incidents
because it was some other crossbow
wielding maniac but not surprisingly the
jury did not believe weinkoff's claim of
another crossbower menacing the
ex-girlfriend and awarded her 1.3
million dollars in damages plus over 900
thousand dollars in attorney's fees and
costs in march 2022 the california court
of appeals upheld the multi-million
dollar judgment the takeaway here though
is while there may be hypothetically
situations where a crossbow can solve
your problems a broken heart is not one
of those things obviously for that you
need a trebuchet
but that takes us to the florida judge
who throws down with the public defender
and gets thrown off the bench because
when a headline begins with florida man
or florida woman you know you're about
to read something that's equal parts
bonkers hilarious and just a dash of i'm
so glad that that's not me
but when the headline is floor to judge
well it's all those things ramped up to
11. and such was the tale of john c
murphy a florida judge who decided to
settle a procedural dispute with a
public defender in the most floridian
way possible by challenging him to a
fistfight
no i think about it i mean
duel challenging someone to a duel is
probably the most floridian way but
fistfight is a close second i demand
satisfaction oh i challenge you to a
duel hey a duel anyway on june 2nd 2014
assistant public defender andrew
weinstock and brevard county judge john
murphy were engaged in a war of words
over mr weinstock's refusal to waive his
clients right to a speedy trial which is
a very routine matter that is typically
resolved amicably in open court with
words but not this judge no when
weinstock refused to waive his client's
speedy trial rights judge murphy
exploded if you want to fight let's go
out back and i'll just look around
but weinstock stood his ground against
the iraq jurist and that's when judge
murphy decided to turn his pre-trial
hearing into a trial by combat
unfortunately as weinstock would soon
see judge murphy a former colonel in the
army an afghanistan veteran had plenty
of experience settling disputes on the
battlefield weinstock follows judge
murphy out of the courtroom and into the
hallway as sounds of a struggle can be
heard off-camera and according to
reports a sheriff's deputy witnessed the
men gripping one another around the
collars of their suit jackets while
screaming the florida judge allegedly
punched weinstock in the face before a
pair of deputies broke up the fight
weinstock was reassigned to another
courtroom to avoid a second
confrontation when judge murphy returned
to the courtroom because this is florida
he was greeted with laughter and
thunderous applause
i will catch my breath eventually
man i'm an old man
but with weinstock no longer present to
defend his clients judge murphy obtained
speedy trial waivers from weinstock's
unrepresented defendants probably
because they had just seen the judge
pummel the crap out of their lawyer in
bird culture this is considered a dick
move but it's also what we lawyer guys
refer to as a huge ethical violation
judge murphy issued a public apology
enrolled in anger management classes and
took a four-week paid leave of absence
and was reassigned from criminal to
civil cases
weinstock resigned in protest after
public defender blaise treatise declared
his support for judge murphy's return to
the bench
judge murphy went viral for the video
and was dubbed the fighting judge but
not everyone was amused in 2015 the
supreme court of florida removed judge
murphy from the bench overruling the
state disciplinary board which
again i can't emphasize this enough
because it was florida
only had recommended a four-month
suspension and a 50 000 fine the court
acknowledged quote it is without
question that except for the june 2nd
2014 incident judge murphy had been a
good judge nevertheless the court
concluded that judge murphy had quote
surrendered his privilege to serve as a
judge after threatening violence against
the attorney appearing before him
fighting that attorney and then inducing
the attorney's unrepresented clients to
accept speedy trial waivers quote judge
murphy's total lack of self-control
became a national spectacle an
embarrassment not only to the judge
himself but also to florida's judicial
system given the clear erosion of public
confidence in the judiciary caused by
his misconduct removal is an appropriate
sanction and i have to say if there's
one takeaway from this case it's that
not even the honor of being an elected
judge is enough to overcome the force
that compels residents of the sunshine
state to transform into florida man but
that takes us to a couple of lawyers you
might have heard something about good
evening america we are mark and patty
mccloskey they are the missouri personal
injury lawyers who spent decades suing
everyone for everything then they waved
their guns at blm protesters became maga
celebrities and then they sued even more
people now personal injury attorneys are
often referred to as ambulance chasers
due to a reputation for filing costly
frivolous suits but in the case of
missouri personal injury lawyers
patricia and mark mccloskey it turns out
all you need to do is basically look at
them the wrong way and they'll sue you
i'll take all your money
if you even look at me funny or they'll
point their guns at your face he'll sue
you he'll put a gun in your face she'll
shoot you probably because of your race
now you've likely seen this viral photo
from june 2020 when the mccloskeys
pointed firearms at blm protesters
marching past their st louis home but
that's not their first public spectacle
here's how jeremy caller of the saint
louis dispatch described the couple
following a review of public records the
mccloskeys are almost always in conflict
with others typically over control of
private property what people can do on
that property and whose job it is to
make sure they do it now among their
many many legal fights it includes suing
to obtain their home a castle originally
built by adolphus bush co-founder of
anheuser-busch suing a man who sold them
a maserati they claimed was supposed to
come with a box of hard defined parts
and fighting their hoa to acquire 1100
square feet of a triangle of lawn
designated as a common area for the
neighborhood now one notable mccloskey
dispute bordered on cartoon villainy in
2013 mark mccloskey allegedly destroyed
beehives placed outside his mansion's
northern wall by the neighboring jewish
central reform congregation then left a
note saying that if the mess wasn't
cleaned up quickly he'd seek a
restraining order and attorney's fees
the congregation was planning to harvest
the honey in apples on the property for
the jewish new year and according to
rabbi susan tolf quote the children were
crying in school it was part of our
curriculum now mark mccloskey denied
destroying the hives and a snopes
investigation was unable to confirm who
killed the bees not the beast not the
beers now flash forward to june 2020
when a group of several hundred blm
demonstrators marched on the home of st
louis mayor linda crewson mayor crewson
had triggered fierce backlash when
during a facebook live post she read the
full names and addresses of george floyd
protesters who had written letters
encouraging her to defund police
departments critics accused her of
doxing critics to open them up to public
harassment and retaliation and on june
28th protesters marched toward cruzen's
home along the street called portland
place which is blocked with heavy iron
gates and signed marked private property
but one of the houses on portland place
is a renaissance-style palazzo owned by
you guessed it patricia and mark
mccloskey when the demonstrators crossed
paths with the mcclassies the pair
countered the protesters first member
rights by threatening them with their
second amendment rights mr mccloskey
stepped onto his patio holding a rifle
and yelled get the hell out of my
neighborhood and private property get
out after mccloskey brandished his rifle
mrs mccloskey then came out of the door
barefoot wielding a small silver pistol
and aimed it directly to the
demonstrators the entire confrontation
lasted about 12 minutes after which the
protesters converged on mayor crewson's
home for several hours of protest but
the mccloskeys immediately became the
couple who launched a thousand memes and
lawsuits because the mccloskeys sued the
photographer who took their viral
photograph the online retailer who used
that photo to sell products with their
unflattering captions and while the
couple became maga celebrities they were
going to be beat up badly and the house
was going to be totally ransacked and
probably burned down like they tried to
burn down churches in june 2021 the
mccloskeys pleaded guilty to misdemeanor
offenses mark for fourth degree assault
with a 750 fine and patricia for
harassment with a 2 000 fine the couple
was required to surrender their guns for
destruction and mark mccloskey wasted no
time in blaming the person actually
responsible for all of this
george soros but in august of 2021
missouri governor mike parson pardoned
the mccloskeys which he had promised to
do if they were convicted the
mccloskey's true to form then
immediately sued the city the sheriff
and the state alleging the pardon
entitled them to have their guns
returned and fines refunded but in
february 2022 the missouri supreme court
subjected the mccloskey's law licenses
to a one-year probationary period after
the ruling mark pelosi said that he was
disappointed the court disciplined him
at all and announced he was considering
asking the u.s supreme court to review
the case now if you're a terrible lawyer
trying to evade public scrutiny or just
a normal person trying to boost your
privacy try today's sponsored nordvpn
because you know that incognito mode
actually isn't incognito right well with
nordvpn's no logs policy your internet
service provider doesn't get to snoop on
what you're searching and neither does
nordvpn with nord you can surf the web
anonymously and your location stays
private so i can log into my favorite
streaming sites and see the libraries
that are available in other countries
and that's just one use case and when
i'm out of the country and i try to
connect to my gmail or a bunch of other
things that i'm logged into all those
accounts would usually freak out and
tell me that i'm being hacked by someone
in whatever location that i'm actually
in so now i just reroute my connection
to the us and my gmail and everything
else is happy and that's one reason to
use nordvpn but nordvpn has become this
way bigger threat protection tool too it
has all these great features like
blocking malware and malicious ad
trackers it's a great tool and all this
is incredibly easy to use so if you'd
like to give nordvpn a try click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description to get a two-year
plan plus four additional months free
with a huge discount and is completely
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee again get a two-year plan plus
four free months at a huge discount by
clicking on the link below and after
that click on this playlist over here
for more legal eagle or i'll see you in
court